with everything going on in the world we
figured now would be a perfect time to
bring back this segment trailers
revisited we started this segment up a
while ago and for some reason we just
didn't continue it even though it was
going well and because you know a lot of
new trailers aren't gonna be coming out
I was like listen bring this back
because this was fun to do and I don't
know why we stopped doing it basically
would trailers to visit what we do is we
determine how accurately portrayed a
movie is if it's spoiler if ik toe and
we it's actually really fun analysis to
do because trailers are performing it of
itself we're gonna look at the most
requested one from the last video we did
which was like a year ago I'm bummed
that we never did it but with the Batman
being delayed let's finally do it it's
the Dark Knight we're gonna look at the
first official trailer not the teaser
one and then let's play the game of
trailers revisited
[Music]
where do we begin here we go these cops
and lawyers wouldn't dare to cross any
of you I mean what happened so what are
you proposing
it's simple kill the Batman
here's my damn sure that they'd love
Gotham Hospital forgot that because told
me everything about you know certainly
hope that you won't still with me
together
did you mean it please don't make me
your only hope
your outfit right that's awesome
a psychotic ex-boyfriends I should be
aware of you rather make this trailer
today yeah
[Music]
I've seen now would have to become to
stop men like him the night is darkest
just before the dawn I promise you the
dawn is coming
[Music]
it's a little gray trailer yeah
all-city deserves a better class of
criminal
see
I mean trailer breakdown sort of that is
easily able to tell that's what Harvey
yeah yeah to see yourself become the
villain
[Music]
will you beat one in the back picture a
little the day alfred sweet long times
I've seen this trailer it's been a very
long time actually I think for the most
part it does a really good job at
advertising and I don't feel like any of
it is false but there's definitely
things that are alternate takes oh yeah
I think nowadays of the way how people
do trailer breakdowns channels like new
rock stars or emergency awesome I feel
like this would be a spoiler trailer for
a good amount of stuff I don't know how
it was back then if people were able to
truly like do this crazy analysis and
determine this moment this most I should
stuff with Harvey Dent we didn't know a
hundred percent for sure if Harvey Dent
would become two-faced in this film and
then you just slowed down the images
here it's like oh it's obviously gonna
be this moment where the guests gasoline
is gonna go on his face and stuff and
there's a shot in the car for you just
pause it you can see it yeah exactly
confirming that yeah he does become
two-faced in this film I think it's
funny watching this trailer because this
looks like a sequel to Batman Begins in
the sense that they advertise it in a
way that has just Joker versus Batman
and then there's some other stuff going
on right that's what the trailer at
least makes it feel like that it's just
Joker and Batman going toe-to-toe the
music that they chose for this makes it
just feel like a cool fun adventure with
some epic action going on when really
what ended up happening with this movie
is that people walked out thinking about
the in Samba thinking about how it feels
akin to the movie heat that it feels
like a crime epic I think one thing this
trailer dove doesn't really communicate
to mean other than some like lines a
dialogue but in terms of the music and
tone is the Menace and how harrowing all
this really will end up feeling I
remember the first time I watched it how
much more bleak it all felt and here
they really got like the comic-book
action adventure spirit in here that's
not really the tone of the movie in a
tone of that movies a lot darker than
what this is what makes it look
or action-oriented than perhaps it
actually is like there's very distinct
action there's very iconic action but
there's a lot of it packed together in
this trailer to kind of push that
towards the forefront I feel like but
yes you know the movies action is like I
said iconic but it isn't the point it
comes fully out of the story points and
all that stuff one thing that I'm sure
everyone's noticed by now is the
alternate takes specifically in the
scene where Joker's talking with the
mobsters yeah they kill the Batman line
is different it's simple kill the Batman
it's simple we kill one of the cops and
lawyers yeah here we go
these cops and lawyers wouldn't dare
cross any of you I mean what happened
let's wind the clocks back a year these
cops and lawyers wouldn't dare cross any
of you I mean what happened here's my
card
is the most noticeably different take I
think here's my card here's my card what
I really fancied about this trailer this
timed is it Christopher Nolan who cuts
his own cuz I'm not sure it really feels
like this movie this trailer intimately
knew the movie because it seemed to have
an arc to me it had like a visual
language that I don't think a lot of
trailers always do because you know you
take that cops and lawyers line you've
got the Joker coming in you see Gordon
then you see dent then you see the
criminals so we know kind of all the key
players and then they start building up
the Batman vs. the Joker and also Batman
versus Harvey kind of different dynamics
and then by the end you've got the
full-on head-to-head yeah you know and
even just quick cuts that really punch
certain lines like the whole disease she
have any crazy ex-boyfriends you have no
idea immediately cut to Batman
smashing a car see I thought this
trailer was really conscientious in the
way that it yeah lays out what feels
like a complete movie the trailer goes
in a direction where it never seems to
double back and especially if you know
the movie there are some moments like
the hospital explosion that's worked in
early that I feel like is kind of
they're too intense the Menace of the
Joker for the trailer and then you see
the desperation with Harvey and all that
stuff later on and so yeah I think
that even though it doesn't hint at the
full extent of like you said how
harrowing this is all gonna be I think
as far as trailers go this one stands
out as being pretty iconic in and of
itself it's because it's such a piece
and it's pretty accurate for the most
part some stuff that the movie focuses
on that you don't really get a strong
sense of here I would say is actually
specifically Gordon because Gordon is
such a big character in The Dark Knight
that showdown final scene where Dent is
doing the coin toss up and then he's got
Gordon's kid and Gordon's like pleading
like that's a big freakin moment and his
journey in it is just as integral like
he's being pushed a breaking point by
the end of the film - and he's not
really showcased here and I get it just
the first trailer but that's the whole
point of this segment is to babyco about
like what's the trailer not really
honing in on that the movie definitely
focuses in on a lot oh and as I'm
editing this I'm also noticing how
there's no Eric Roberts present I mean
he's kind of in the background a
one-shot a Salvatore Maroni which was
another integral piece and really kicked
off a lot of the plot to this movie and
I think another fun thing to note about
this beyond Batman is that this is a
Nolan film and Nolan trailers would not
be this way today that's true like after
inception which came after this movie
Nolan trailers became definitive and how
they're done yeah which is just music
maybe a few things time Hagen and why
that's the same kind of text that even
the Dark Knight Rises if you remember
that trailer being pretty mysterious for
the most part and Nolan trailers have a
very specific style like Tennant is
exactly in tune with the way although
the trailers should go this does not
feel like a Christopher Nolan trailer Oh
like this is more like a general trailer
if anything that's I was curious I said
we were watching like how would they
make this trailer today this really put
the name Christopher Nolan on the map
The Dark Knight specifically way more
than Batman Begins and they solidified
that name stamp with inception I mean
yes a lot of us did already follow his
work prior but it's like you were
talking about Nolan cutting his own
trailers and I really think that if this
came out just even a few years ago or
post inception mm-hmm this would be a
wildly differ
trailer oh yeah but yeah this was fun to
look at yeah and I mean I haven't seen
this trailer in literally many years
yeah so yeah this was a nice blast from
the past
all right guys well the dark night what
other trailers do you think we should
revisit leave your suggestions down
below it's might be a semi we want to
bring back weekly I don't know let me
stop doing subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell last but
not least let's end this with a peep
dawn and prawns with dawn Johnson in
Wisconsin doing cross feet in a ball pit
with Ryan Gosling if your balls with
chopsticks like a Brad Pitt on acid slip
Willie's flossing he james marsden the 1
peter color carpet cleaner on Easter
morning with Pierce Brosnan hogging all
the dog [ __ ] like a barking and alan
walking in the darkness
dawn feet clubbing in a party with Marty
McFly listening to Bob Marley traveling
back in time like Arnold Don Pedro
seriously though thanks so much for all
your love and support over time I really
hope that you're doing well amid all the
craziness that's going on in the world
keep on writing keep on getting out you
can't get out there - some of the things
you love right now but I hope you're
doing okay at home I hope you're keeping
creative this is the time for it and
thanks for all you mean you've been with
us for a long time and that really means
a lot so seriously thank you hope you're
doing well catch you on the next one
it's exchange bazan